[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تسمى السنه الربيعيه اذا امطرت السماء
بسته امطار سينيه خلال اربع مواسم سهيل
الوسم المربعانيه الشغل من سبتمبر الى
ابريل واذا ربعت الارض افضل انواع الربيع
على اراضي الحرات الحرات عرعر وتبوك
والمدينه وحايل وافضل انواع الحمض على نجم
ولهذا تسمى بنجد العديه وكثافه الربيع
لهذه السنه واكثر نظاره على الحجاز في
المنطقه الواقعه بين مكه وجده ليش لان
جاهم واسمن طيب واذا نزل المطر يعاقبه
ربيع والربيع يطلع الفقع والفقع يجلب
الجراد وهنا الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون
اذا طلع الفجر
انفردها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ونحن نشتاق الى المطر وننتظره على احر من
الجمر خاصه اذا انقطع عنا ولذلك النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول اللهم اغثنا فالغيث
هو المطر الذي ياتينا بعد انقطاعا طويل
والمطر يسمى عند العرب القدماء بالطش
واوله يسمى بالرشح ولهذا من العبارات
الترحيبيه عند العرب القدماء اهلا
الاولين الله يرحمهم والبيض مثقف واهل
الخليج يقولون ومايا الورد
[موسيقى]